SPEAKER 1: On August 5, 1857, a
4,300-kilometer-long cable was
laid across the Atlantic Ocean.
It provided a link between
Britain and the Americas,
further strengthening their
social and economic alliances.
Now, information
could be represented
as a pattern of
electrical pulses
and sent across the world
almost instantaneously.
Stock tickers and
money transfers,
these were commercial
applications
invented by Western
Union which ushered
in a new era of
global communication.
SPEAKER 2: Stand by
for this announcement.
Germany has invaded Poland
and has bombed many towns.
General mobilization has been
ordered in Britain and France.
SPEAKER 3: And
consequently, this country
is at war with Germany.
SPEAKER 4:
--throughout the world
which is the real
cause of the war,
that today threatens
the freedom of mankind.
SPEAKER 5:
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
SPEAKER 6:
SPEAKER 7: The Japanese have
attacked Pearl Harbor, Hawaii
by air, President Roosevelt
has just announced.
ADOLPH HITLER: [SPEAKING GERMAN]
SPEAKER 1: During World War
II, Germany, Italy, and Japan
were far outnumbered
by the Allies.
Their only conceivable
path the victory
was the ability to launch
widespread surprise attacks.
So the goal of
encryption technology
was to automate the one-time
pad using an encryption machine.
Ideally, this machine would
accept an input letter,
apply a random shift, and
output the encrypted letter.
However, all machines
follow the same principle.
They begin in some initial
configuration known as a state.
They accept some input.
They do an operation
with the input.
And then they produce an output.
The operation from initial
state to final state
is always predictable
and repeatable.
So the goal was to produce
identical machines that
output a scrambled
sequence of shifts
which took a long
time to repeat.
Therefore Alice and Bob could
generate an identical shift
sequence as follows.
First, they need to
share identical machines
and agree on an
initial position, which
is defined as the key setting.
Then, they align their
machines to the same position.
And finally, cycle through
the identical operations
to achieve identical sequences.
Now the state of the art
technology at the time
was called a rotor
encryption machine.
We are all familiar with
the mechanical process
of an odometer which
takes a long time
to finally repeat its cycle.
Now, imagine we
scrambled the numbers
on the wheels of the odometer.
When it ticks
forward, a new shift
could be generated by adding
up each number on the rotors.
This is the rough idea behind
rotor encryption machines.
For example, the message
"attack northwest"
would be encrypted as follows.
Notice how a new shift
is used at each position
in the message.
With three rotors,
each with 26 numbers,
the length of this
sequence, before repeating,
is 26 times 26 times 26.
This is equivalent to
having a list of shifts
17,576 numbers long.
Understand that
each rotor position
is equivalent to a
location in this sequence.
The initial machine state
is known as the key setting.
And the collection of
all possible key settings
defines the key space.
This key space increases
if the number of ways
to initially configure
the machine increases.
For example, if the
rotors can be rearranged,
then the order can be
selected in six ways.
Let's visualize the key
space at this point.
First, we choose from one of
six possible rotor orderings.
Then we select an
initial position
from the rotor sequence.
This gives us a key space with
over 100,000 key settings.
Remember, every
machine configuration
is a point in this space.
When we select a key setting, we
are selecting a starting point
in this space which
then determines
the rest of the shift sequence.
Give away the key
setting, and you give away
the entire sequence.
The security of rotor
machines depends
on both the size
of this key space
and the randomness
of the key setting.
During World War II, one of
the most important encryption
technologies used by
the German military
was known as the Enigma.
It was an electromechanical
rotor machine
invented by a German engineer
at the end of World War
I. Each rotor wheel
had electrical contacts
on either side with a
maze of wirings within.
So at each rotor position,
there was an electrical path
from every input letter
to every output letter.
When the rotor advanced,
an entirely new path
was defined for each letter.
During the war, they
continually tried
to increase the key
space of the Enigma
in order to make it stronger.
For example, some
changes they made
were to add a fourth
rotor wheel and increase
the number of possible rotors
you could put into the machine
to 60.
This had the effect of massively
increasing the key space.
Near the end of
the war, the Enigma
could be set up in over 150
million million million ways.
Guessing the key setting which
was used for a given message
was about as likely as guessing
the outcome of 26 dice roles.
This gave the Germans
confidence that the Allies,
even if they had a
copy of the Enigma,
could never check all
possible key settings.
For two parties to
communicate using the Enigma,
it required that they first
share the daily key settings.
This allowed them to align their
machines to the same position.
This protocol changed over
and over during the war
but generally involved
distributing key sheets
in advance to all operators.
Each day, the operator would
cut off the daily settings.
And this would tell them
the daily configuration
of their machines, such
as what rotors to use
and the order of the rotors.
This key setting was then
to be destroyed after use.
However, one vital step
was left to the operator.
They were to select a random
initial position of each rotor
before communication began.
And a very simple
mistake was made
by some fatigued operators.
We make this exact
same mistake every time
we set up a bike
lock combination
because we tend to
rotate this cylinder only
a few clicks from
the initial state.
Or we reuse a common password.
This destroyed the
uniform distribution
of the initial rotor position.
And after repeated observations,
it allowed the Allies
to reverse engineer the
rotor wirings completely.
The second major error
was a design error
not a procedural one.
The Enigma was designed, so
that an input letter would never
encrypt to itself.
So given an encrypted
letter, such as L,
you can now eliminate
the possibility
that L was the original letter.
What they thought was
a strength was actually
a weakness in design.
And this led to a code-breaking
machine initially designed
by the Poles and later improved
by the British American effort.
The bombe was a multiple
Enigma rotors chained together,
allowing it to rapidly test
different key settings.
It took advantage of the
fact that common words
were known to be in the original
message, such as the weather.
And these came to
be known as cribs.
For a given message
in crib, the bombe
could scan through all possible
rotor positions and orders
in order to find
possible key settings
in a matter of minutes.
This machine allowed the
Allies to read German commands
within hours of
them being issued.
It was a fatal blow to
their combat strategy
as the Allies could
anticipate their next move.
One fact remains,
this initial attempt
at automating the
one-time pad failed.
If the operators had
instead rolled dice
to decide their initial
rotor positions,
the starting point
in the sequence
could have been
uniformly distributed.
This would have prevented
the reverse engineering
of the rotor wirings.
And if the Enigma
allowed letters
to be encrypted to
themselves, the bombe
could not have taken
advantage of cribs.
And this would have
required the Allies
to check the entire key
space which was impossible,
even with the fastest computer.
Repetition reduced
the key space.
Otherwise, the outcome
of World War II
could have been
drastically different.